hello world my name is Amy Keith BAE and
I'm Eric lightning Schlag and we're here
to you today from the mobile ads
developer relations team today we'll
talk about migrating Google Play
services what Google Play services is
why you should migrate and the
nitty-gritty of actually changing your
code from the old AdMob app to your new
Google Play services app so first I'm
going to talk about what is Google Play
services and why you should upgrade your
AdMob apps to use Google Play services
so Google Play services is an apk that's
distributed to the Google Play Store it
gives you access to the latest and
greatest google android api s and now
Google AdMob is part the api's are part
of Google Play services and the great
advantage of using the Google Play
services API is is that devices with the
Google Play Store can get updates to the
library with that without you having to
re-release your app so if you push your
app with version 1 of Google Play
services with with AdMob in it and you
know that mom makes changes and pushes
out a v2 onto those devices your app
will start running v2 and take advantage
of the the latest fixes to the library
so you should update to Google Play
services because you will get these
automatic platform updates which will be
a huge advantage we'll also just give
you better api as we've totally revamped
a lot of the API to do things the
Android way hopefully you'll find them
better and more intuitive and then this
will also be the platform of choice
going forward so we won't continue the
iterate on the standalone AdMob SDK but
all of our new changes will go to the
Google Play services library so we hope
that you can upgrade so you can keep
with the latest updates that we have so
now we're going to talk about how to
migrate from the old library to the new
Google Play services API s so previously
when integrating the library you just
had a jar and you would put that jar
into the libs folder for AdMob 6 for 1
below and Google Play services you
actually have to integrate the Google
Play services library project and then
reference that project into your
application so there's a there's a
difference there and then you'll also be
using the comm kugel Android JMS adds
names
when referencing on the classes instead
of the conduct without ads namespace
when you declare an ad activity in your
manifest XML then you'll also have to
make a few minor changes first you'll be
changing the name space from comm kugel
adds dot add activity to comm kugel
android GMS dot add activity again we'll
be changing that namespace all across
your app the other thing is you'll have
to add this metadata tag for the Android
Play services version so you'll use
comic Google Android gia messed up
version and import the Play services
version also it's important to note that
all of your permissions and everything
else will stay the same so you don't
have to worry about that when updating
your app so now I'm going to talk about
creating an ad view so in AdMob 641 when
you created the ad view and the
constructor you'd pass the activity
context the ad size and your ad unity in
Google Play services we're doing at the
Android way we're in a view object only
needs to take the activity context so
you just create a new ad view with your
activity context and then they're set ad
unit ID and set ad size methods to set
the ad size and pass your edudentity
note that these should only be called
once if you do it again you'll get an
illegal State exception but there should
be no reason you have to call it more
than once when you create an ad request
you will no longer be creating this ad
request and then adding a test device or
doing these other changes directly to
the ad request instead we've moved to
the Builder paradigm so you'll create an
ad request builder everything you'll do
will be done to this builder the builder
is an immutable object so everything you
do to it will actually be creating a new
builder so you won't be able to mess
things up in the middle of running your
application and then once you've
actually made all of your changes of the
builder for example adding a test of ice
then you actually build a builder to
create the ad request we should also
note that the
identifier to get test ads on emulators
changed from ad request test emulator to
ad request a device ID emulator next
we'll talk about creating a new ad
listener object so we changed the ad
listener object previously in the
standalone SDK the ad listener object
was an interface so you would extend
your activity with this ad listener
object and implement all of these
methods in order to track what's going
on now in the new Google Play services
version we have an abstract class and
you'll be able to actually just create
that an ad listener object on the fly
override the methods that you need and
leave all of the rest alone one thing to
note is that we've changed the error
code so now the error code is just an
integer and you'll have to create a new
method in order to extract meaning from
that integer the other thing is that
we've changed all of the names of the
methods so on receive add is now on add
loaded on fail to receive add is now on
failed on add fail to load and all of
these changes are just one-to-one you it
shouldn't be difficult to change from
one to the other and then all of the
methods name will be more consistent
with the Android way of doing things so
now I'm going to talk about the
implementation of an ad listener and
setting it on the ad view
so when we had the interface your class
that implemented the ad listener would
have to implement all of the method the
add event methods in that interface and
then finally called a view dot set add
listener with the object that
implemented the add listener and Google
Play services we use an abstract class
and so you can actually just call a bead
set add listener and create a new add
listener and inline like a sub class and
just override the events that you care
about so in this example we have on add
loaded and on add failed to load
implemented but we don't have to
implement the rest of the methods here
next we'll talk about creating an ad
view in XML previously you were able to
do everything in the XML if you wanted
to have a very simple ad view now we'll
have to actually write a little bit of
code but first let's talk about the
changes in the XML so the main changes
in the XML are that you'll have to you
won't be able to use add test devices
and add load on create in your XML so
you'll have to add a test device in the
code and you also won't be able to just
load an ad on create in the XML you'll
have to remove those attributes the
other thing to notice is that you'll
have to change your name space from libs
com apk /lib comm that google about adds
to apk /res Auto that's all going to be
Auto all the way imported and Eric's
going to talk to you about the changes
in the code yep so that changes in the
code for the XML LabVIEW and Google Play
services is you'll have to grab the add
view from the XML creating new ad
request via the Builder pattern and call
load ad with that ad request as Amy
mentioned in 6.4 that one there was
actually no code required if you had
used the load on create attribute to be
true but also note that if you want to
do anything more complicated like set an
ad listener you'll still need to write
some code in both either 6:41 for Google
Play services and that hasn't changed
now we'll talk about the add view
lifecycle methods so previously in the
standalone SDK we only had V dot destroy
now we have add V destroy Abdullah pause
and add be resumed these methods are all
allow you to destroy pause or resume a
webview so this gives you a little bit
more control over what's actually going
on in your life cycle and I'm going to
talk about passing extras to AdMob you
can do things like set the background
color and text of your ad and that would
be done through extras so in 641 you
would create the new ad request you
would create a new AdMob adapter extras
object and pass the occult add extra and
pass like key value pairs for like
background color and text for example
and then call set Network extras with
that object
in Google Play services it's done a
little bit differently you have an AdMob
extras instead of an AdMob adapter
extras and it accepts a bundle which you
have to create before you create the
AdMob extras class um so you create a
new bundle put string on your key value
pairs create the AdMob extras object and
then finally when you're creating the ad
request using the Builder pattern you
just call add Network extras with those
extras and build in so we know we've
made a lot of changes to the SDK so
there's been a couple questions we're
going to address three of the most
frequently asked questions the first one
is does Google Play services support
existing mediation adapters the answer
is yes we've made sure that none of your
mediation should break so if you upgrade
the Google Play services today all of
your mediation should work as expected
the mediation adapters will be the same
for a long time in the future if we do
iterate on mediation and expect
mediation adapters to update we still
plan on supporting legacy mediation for
quite a while in the future the next
question you guys have had is will
Google Play services API is work on
devices without Google Play services
installed and it does the only
difference is that you won't get to take
advantage of the auto updates so if you
push your app on to a Kindle that's
using the ads API s and Google Play
services you that app won't get any
updates if Google Play pushes like a new
version of the AdMob live API is in the
Google Play services library but for
devices that do have Google Play service
installed it will automatically get
those updates and be running against the
latest version of our library the last
question is if Google Play services is
compatible with the old standalone AdMob
SDK the answer is no unfortunately this
was a side effect of trying to keep
mediation compatible with the new SDK
however you should expect DFP and search
ads for apps and everything else now in
the new Google Play services SDK so you
shouldn't lose any of that functionality
I should be able to upgrade everything
to Google Play services the other thing
is if you are working with a library
that's dependent on the old SDK then we
hope that you can urge those library
developers
upgrade to the new Google Play services
since that's where we'll be pushing all
updates from now on so we've given you a
lot of information and it might take
some time for it to sink in if you here
are some more resources that you can use
if you have more questions so first you
should check out the Google Play
services set up because that explains
how to get Google Play services library
into your app so you can reference it
and then if you want to reference
anything else that we talked about today
you can check out the Google Play
services migration guide it has a lot of
the same information if you have any
trouble upgrading you can always hit up
me and Eric on the forums you can also
talk to other AdMob developers there and
see if they've had the same troubles
that you have we hope that this has been
helpful and we hope that you can enjoy
the new version of the AdMob SDK thank
you thanks guys